the frontal lobe is tied into emotion
and inhibition and things like that so
when somebody one of your buddies has
too many beers and he's naked on the
table with a lampshade on that's frontal
and cerebellar inhibition they they lose
those inhibitory systems so they start
thinking yeah this is a good idea hold
my beer kind of thing so so we want to
do stuff to make those inhibitory
systems stronger and so that that you
know your whole brain is a gas-breaking
knowledge you have to have a ghost
system but you have to have a stop
system so we also did some stuff with
you like anti-seconds and dual tasking
and whatnot and what those are is that
if anyone's played the game Simon says
go Simon says stop go well that's for
you know our tendency is to want to go
right and to you know you have to have
that inhibitory system and say oh Simon
didn't say and so we use that like we do
a lot with neurodevelopmental stuff with
like autistic kids and things like that
so those are just examples of those
inhibitory systems of the brain that
even though there's not as many neurons
for it they actually have more energy in
their own system and those kind of
things that's why a lot of people have
anxiety and ocp because they don't get
it turned off it doesn't shut down yeah
so we'll do exercises like anti-seconds
and go no-go like Simon says stuff and
things like that to activate those
Pathways to get that those Pathways
stronger because anything you do
repetitively in the brain like learning
a new golf swing that will ultimately
start to create new Pathways and then
over time when you've reinforced it
enough that's your new normal that's the
beauty about brain plasticity as long as
you're living and breathing you can you
can be 85 years old and get your brain
function working better so it's a
beautiful thing that we have going for
us on that front you could always rehab
the brain
um we also worked with gaze
stabilization too what part does gaze
stabilization have
um on how someone feels and what would
reduce somebody's ability to have that
gay stabilization and
um and then and then I found it totally
fascinating to understand just how sort
of exhausting that probably was to my
system because my eyes didn't stay
focused gotcha yeah that's a great
question because the gays holding
centers in your brain stem it happens to
be right by where the vagus nerve is
actually they're right next to each
other and it's really correlated or are
they just next week exactly for sure
they're correlated well technically the
whole nervous system even though we try
and compartmentalize it there's a lot of
interconnectivity so I don't want to be
you know like left brain right but at
the end of the day they're like brother
and sister right next to each other
because gay centers are your part of
your balance Center okay the main part
of gaze holding is your balance center
it's the fastest reflex in the human
body it's faster than Vision so our
ability to look at Target and move our
eyes our head around I'm sorry move our
head around that Target fastest reflux
of the human body one of the things we
see a lot in concussions and whatnot is
because that's in the brain stem well if
your head's getting rattled around as
you're you'll say you're in your Nascar
or your cart Open Wheel and you take a
head or even just the you know normal
driving spirit that where's the brain
it's floating around that fluid but
what's it floating on your brain stem so
that poor area of the brain is getting a
lot of trauma and a lot of shearing and
things like that so one of the
mechanisms is actual direct mechanical
damage to that area well that's our eyes
are basically if I took your brain and
just squeezed it out of your skull and
it popped out that's your eyes okay you
can basically with eye movements and eye
analysis see a lot no pun intended you
can analyze a lot of what's going on in
the brain based on eye movements and
Optics and ocular motor stuff so one of
the first things we look at in things
like post-concussion is can the eyes
lock on a Target didn't stay on that
Target and if they can't we that's one
of our first orders of business is to do
gaze holding exercises uh or what are
called vestibular ocular therapies to
get the eyes stable so that your balance
is better your awareness of where you
are in space your reaction time is
better you don't fall that's a big thing
what do they tell you in yoga if you're
doing a balance pose like tree and
you're all over the place that your yoga
instructor will tell you to walk and
fixate on it exactly you're drishy yes
exactly so that's your gays holding
centers so one of our first building
blocks like when we build your nervous
system back up you have to be able to
have those eyes locked in place so we
worked a lot with you to develop that
foundation so that everything else we
did above it was coming from a good
foundation like that what is the normal
amount of eye movements in a day
something a hundred and two thousand
thousand you know estimates are around
100 to 120 000 kind of thing and you
were probably doing about four or five
hundred thousand eye movements a day
because of all of your extraneous
activity and re you know Corrections and
stuff yeah just your eyes are skeletal
muscle if I'm at the gym and I had you
do three sets of ten with bicep curls
and you're like I can't do anymore I got
lactic acid I'm tired and I say you know
what do five more of the five more sets
of those what do you think your muscles
gonna do right what do you think your
body is going to do that's anaerobic
respiration it's you know you're
building up you know talk you know free
radicals it's exhausting you're using up
energy unnecessarily so we want the
nervous system to be efficient and by
getting all those extraneous eye
movements out of your equation your
system is going to have a lot more
energy to work with to do all the fun
stuff you like to do let's talk about uh
stress diet lifestyle
um emotions
um toxins like how is there a way to
organize it in a hierarchy or is it are
they all sort of in their own Silo
affecting the system to a similar degree
I love that question because they do
have their all their own damning
qualities about it but I if I were to
try and put a hierarchy on it I would
say one thing stress is the underpinning
for a lot of our problems and it whacks
those areas of the brain like the
hippocampus your memory Center one of
the worst ways you can whack that is
stress so we have to get stress out of
our system we have to get you know into
whether it's our relationships our
careers whatever you know Finding ways
to go ground
yeah exactly
um so yeah for sure that's a big one the
next one I would say is move you have to
move you know they've they've done
studies and I just put a new one up in
my slide that they just came up with a
study where they compare diet and
exercise together they compared that in
relation to exercise alone diet and
lifestyle like the nutrition stuff alone
and then none of the above and what they
showed is that if you exercised you
could overcome the dietary stuff with
the negative qualities of diet now I
don't want to just give give people the
green light to go eat yeah but it's just
it's just a hierarchy yeah so get out
and move we become way too sedentary I
don't care what kind of movement is
there is there a certain recommended do
you need to work at like do you need to
have interval style training is it uh uh
time under tension with muscles with
lifting weights is it just purely
walking like what would you recommend I
at the end of the day I'm like I'm okay
with just getting out and walking
because if somebody's just sitting at
their desk all day and they get out and
walk that's going to be a game changer
but you brought up an excellent point
high intensity interval training is
arguably the best way to get new nerve
growth factors and insulin resistance
under control and things like that so if
we and the good thing about hit training
is like they just did a study that
showed five minutes of that or six
minutes technically could help prevent
Alzheimer's so when patients tell me I
don't have time to work out if you can't
give me three minutes of your day you
know then what it what are you supposed
to do as a doctor as a patient you know
you give me three minutes of high
intensity interval training and that's
going to make huge changes in your brain
and your chemistry and your neuronal
health so what we do with high intensity
interval training is one minute on one
minute off one minute on and we do that
times three minutes that it could be
jump rope it can be elliptical trainer
whatever whatever it is you're doing
just do it in in training in intervals
even if you're going for a walk change
go really brisk for a while and then
slow it down and change it up that way
complex movement patterns big like yoga
Tai Chi there you go so new things
novelty is big for the brain learning
yeah a new golf swing or learning how to
you know play tennis or whatever
anything that learn how to play the
piano like anything that stimulates the
brain is helps with that neuroplasticity
correct exactly exactly no near New
neural Pathways now you brought us
really big points though like toxins and
viruses and stuff those things will just
you know you have to be able to address
those and get them under control and or
get them out of the body so so we look
at you know heavy metal readings like
hair analysis and different things like
that urine analysis we viruses are like
you talk about a major underpinning this
is why a lot of long coveted people are
showing dementia stuff is that now that
it's going along we're seeing some of
the effects of that so we need to do
stuff to to address the immunology and
that's why lasers are so good because
they can actually go after a lot of the
stuff that the pathogens like viruses
are doing to the brain in a bad way the
inflammation the over immune response
like the over inflammation that you know
you hear about the the coveted storm and
all that stuff but so yeah we have if
you if you have a chronic mold exposure
or something good luck having a healthy
brain but in I can say the exact same
thing in a even worse like an iron
deficiency if you're anemic you're never
going to have you know it's almost
impossible to have a healthy body if
iron is involved in every enzyme react
reaction in the human body so we have to
also do low-hanging fruit stuff like a
CBC get labs done on yourself you know
eat good foods that have good iron
sources like good red meat this is a big
misconception is that people like oh
meat's bad yeah West you know when you
have industrialized beef not good and
it's not the meat that's the problem
that's what they put into it the
antibiotics
um food sources fish we can't live
without it they're called essential
fatty acids for a reason so even if you
don't want to eat red meat all right
let's at least eat be a pescetarian yeah
you gotta at least eat fish or have a
fish Source like for your omega-3 fatty
acids so that's a big one so um so I
would say movement stress reduction and
find a practitioner that's more holistic
and integrative that's actually going to
look under all those stones what do you
make about uh people just kind of
dropping dropping to the ground these
days like you know the football player
that the football player that you know
the bills player that
um fell down on the field you look at
you see all these little videos of
people they're soccer players there's
people giving speeches there's people on
television it's basically like just
people doing what they're doing and you
just watch them like does that have to
do with I mean that seems very brain
oriented
yeah and and while they're actually this
one does get down a little bit more to
the cardiovascular level like one of the
top cardiologists I know said we are
seeing more signs of myocardial he's
he's been in practice over 30 years he
said I'm seeing more signs of of cardio
like myocardial inflammation in the last
couple of years and I've seen in 30
years of practice
okay now you know what is myocarditis
it's inflammation of the cardiac tissue
yeah any ideas yeah well okay so it's
like we get into this whole thing I what
I try and do is have a pragmatic
conversation about vaccines all right
I'm sorry but there is risk involved in
vaccines that's just the nature of the
Beast and the problem is you can't you
know if you start to kind of address
vaccine risks you get censored like look
at what happened to Robert Malone he's
like the holiday guy and as soon as he
is thank God for Joe Rogan yeah and so
you know here you've got a guy that
literally got shut down all he was doing
was trying to have a pragmatic
conversation saying look there are risks
involved and we don't know everything
that's going to happen with the MRNA
really all that stuff so it and I'm
seeing you know vaccine injuries more
than I ever have and most of it is
cardiovascular based so you know
endothelial inflammation and things like
that as well as dysautonomia both in
covet and with the vaccine what that is
you've heard of conditions like pots and
things like that that happens in the
brain stem and that's where because we
talked about remember we just talked
about how the eyes and the balance
Center were directly with brother and
sister to your cardiac like your veins
stuff and things like that yeah and that
area gets hit hard with a lot of these
things it even gets hit hard with mold
for example and so then what happens is
people have problems when they go to
stand up they don't have the right blood
pressure they don't have the right heart
rate and so you could imagine what's
happening to their system when it's
going all over the map because you only
have about four and a half liters of
blood and that brain stem that we're
talking about it's like a traffic cop
says okay Danica's standing up blood
Hugo here Danica's leaning forward blood
you go here that kind of thing okay
we're having a thought you blood you go
here well if it's getting mixed signals
or like with a concussion or it's
inflamed and it's not it's you're
functioning properly like if you have
inflammation like let's say in your core
it's not going to go to your head as
well because it's essentially like a
like a traffic jam if you like this clip
and and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen